max freed on the mound for the home side
last assignment was saturday at miami
six innings of work allowed three earned
runs
on five hits struck out four and walked
two if if you
take freed's first three starts out of
his
line and i know that's this ifs and
butts being candy and nuts i get that
but if you do it
he's been really impressive this year
tommy edmond ready to go to work for
saint louis tonight's edmond has the
base hit into left field maybe more
almante's got to get there in a hurry
tommy can run on his way into second
base
with a lead-off double to a fine start
tonight here's dylan carlson now hitless
yesterday
the cardinals would really love to
translate that lead off double into an
early run after being shut out yesterday
jam shot on a fastball on the ground for
riley
and there is a well-earned
first out of the game for max freed as
edmond takes third
paul goldsmith has had 17 opportunities
with a runner at third and less than two
out and he's gotten him in
eight times this year it's a ground ball
for riley who will concede the run
through the out the rbi to goldsmith
it's one nothing saint louis
so here's arenado now with a running and
two away and he chased a breaking ball
in the dirt and that'll do it in the
saint louis half of the first
carlos martinez inherits a one-nothing
lead before he even
settles in to begin his night some
nights he'll look like bob gibson and
other knights he looks like
another kind of gibson i mean it's
feaster famine with him
ron lacuna junior leads things off for
atlanta and that one actually got away
from him and hit a cuny
hit batsman opens up the ball game and
that's something that's happened with
martinez on the mound
more often than not freddie freeman on
the first pitch into the opposite field
handled at the wall by tyler o'neill
martinez gets him on a fly ball in his
first try tonight now it's ozzie
acuna's running pitch is taken outside
throw to second is in time to get him
and there's the hall of famer at work
see him get out of the shoot in a hurry
accurate throw
and deyoung with a nice sweep tag
albee's has been terrific at home
as albie strokes that one just inside
the line in left field
ozzy on his way to second with a two out
double
35 extra base hits for rozzy albies
there's abraham almonte now
the 3-2 from martinez and he misses with
a change-up boy
it might come as a bit of a surprise to
learn that austin reilly has been as
productive as he's been
there's a line shot out to right field
for austin riley
alby scores and just like that we're
back to even
as atlanta has answered in their half of
the first
one and two to swanson with two runners
aboard to run in
and he gets him on the slider william
contreras will lead things off for the
braves bottom of the second in a 1-1
game
first pitch is sucked to left and deep
way back
that ball is out of here william
contreras has gotten hot with a first
pitch homer
against martinez to make it two to one
atlanta
and there's ball four to acuna
what an interesting little battle we've
got here between yachty molina and ron
lacuna junior
they're now one for one against each
other freddy's had
really good days against carlos martinez
in his career
and a base hit for freeman acuna taking
the turn
throw to the plate is cut freeman's safe
at second
i think the throw made it all the way
through but that was molina who just
opted to go right back to second base
instead of trying for the play of the
play you know one step back
and make that sweep tag with a glove but
he's got him out yeah i'm surprised at
that so is martinez i mean
he's pointing at home plate said why
didn't you do that three to one atlanta
now albies who doubled and scored back
in the first
swings and sends the ball to deep right
and that one is
gone on top of the job
wow ozzie all bees knew as soon as he
made contact that that ball was gonna
fly
and the braves already have five runs
not sure how much longer the cardinals
are going to be able to
avoid going to the bullpen martinez just
has not been sharp tonight
and here come the braves once again in
the fourth inning
ozzy all beings with a fly ball the
other way that drops in
boy it is really ozzie's night acuna
scores
throw to third is not in time throw the
second is in time to get all bees
what they're looking at is whether or
not albies was safe at second base so
it's the braves that actually called for
the appeal
ball's overturned albie's is safe so the
fire good and hot here
a run in nobody out looks like mike
silth has finally seen enough
jake woodford who had been up a couple
of times is ready to go
faces abraham almonte runners at second
and third
and el monte shoots that into left
freeman scores easily
7-1 graves runners at the corners with
two runs in nobody out for austin reilly
sends a drive out to wright
carlson camps under it to make the catch
and it's going to tag
and score albies with a third run of the
inning
only brave that has not been on base
tonight so far
is pitcher max freed trying to rectify
that here with his third plate
appearance
ball four lost him with a bases loaded
walk
i think they batted around when three
dug in yeah
and now the cardinals are just getting
battered around i think the next thing
coming is the mercy rule
ground ball to third as arenado takes
care of him to put a merciful
end to a very long inning max free the
beneficiary
of all the support the o2 home to
o'neill first of all
breaking balls called for a strike three
boy that's half to give a few
calls from the saint louis dugout here's
paul de young now
that ball literally squirted out of
breeds hands
and young can't hold on max freed back
to work
back with his eight-run lead in tow he
has been dominant tonight and
takes care of paul goldschmidt with a
swing and a miss balding two strikes to
nolan arenado
got him on the gas big time velocity
here in the seventh denning for max
breed that's his sperm as he's thrown a
fastball all night
oh there's a breaking ball that gets a
hold up however they got a man there
that's almonte to retire the side
seven strong innings from max friedman
well this might be the final opportunity
for ozzy albies
and a sixth triple of the year if he
does cash in on that three
base hit it would mean he'd hit for the
cycle
into right lane thomas calls everybody
off to retire this side
9-1 advantage and that sets up
jacob webb to try to close down business
at home tonight the cardinals are down
to their final out tonight
thomas sends a drive out to left and
that's how the night ends
abraham almante gathers it in and the
braves have made it two in a row to
start this four-gamer